ITS TARGET LIST.
BUT FIRST, THE ALL BUT FORGOTTEN
AMERICAN TRAGEDY, THAT IS THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE" ."
WHEN DONALD TRUMP ANNOUNCED HIS
CANDIDACY, THE MEDIA REACTED
WITH HORROR TO THIS STATEMENT.
>> WHEN MEXICO SENDS ITS PEOPLE,
THEY ARE NOT SENDING THEIR BEST.
THEY ARE SENDING PEOPLE THAT
HAVE LOTS OF PROBLEMS, AND THEY
ARE BRINGING THOSE PROBLEMS WITH
US.
THEY ARE BRINGING CRIME.
THEY ARE RAPISTS.
AND SOME, I ASSUME, ARE GOOD
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: WHILE MANY, SOME, AT
LEAST, QUIBBLE WITH THE
FORMULATION, THEY KNEW WHAT HE
BASICALLY MEANT.
MAYBE HE SHOULD HAVE SINGLED OUT
MEXICO, PEOPLE FROM A LOT OF
PLACES ARE DOING US HARM.
I'LL TELL YOU TONIGHT THERE IS
CONTINUOUS AND SAD EVIDENCE TO
SUBSTANTIATE CRIMES OF -- THE
UNDERLYING CRIMES.
EVERY DAY THERE ARE FRESH
TRAGEDIES TO REPORT ON.
AMERICAN CITIZENS BRUTALIZED,
ABUSED, MURDERED BY ILLEGAL
ALIENS, YET MOST OF THESE
STORIES ARE BURIED AT THE BACK
OF THE LOCAL METRO SECTIONS IN
YOUR LOCAL PAPER, AND MOST OF
THEM ARE NEVER HEARD NATIONAL
NEWS BROADCASTS.
THE MEDIA ARE TOO BUSY DOING,
WHAT?
CAPTURING EVERY UTTERANCE OF A
FEW SPECIFIC PORN STARS.
TONIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO REPORT
ON A HANDFUL OF THESE AMERICAN
TRAGEDIES.
IN SAN DIEGO, I AM MEXICAN
ILLEGAL ALIEN, AFTER A NIGHT OF
DRINKING, WAS CHARGED WITH
RUNNING A STOP SIGN AND SLAMMING
INTO A FAMILY VEHICLE.
A LITTLE BOY IN THE BACKSEAT OF
THE VEHICLE SUFFERED SERIOUS
HEAD TRAUMA AND NOW HAS
COGNITIVE ISSUES.
HE FLED THE SCENE.
IN ADDITION TO BEING AN ILLEGAL
ALIEN, ACOSTA HAD BEEN DEPORTED
17 TIMES.
YES, AT 17.
OESTREICH, A JUDGE DECLARED
A MISTRIAL IN THIS CASE BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T ESTABLISH IF IT
WAS HE OR THE ILLEGAL ALIEN IN
THE CAR WITH HIM WHO IS ACTUALLY
BEHIND THE WHEEL AT THE TIME OF
THE CRASH.
THANKFULLY, HE WAS TURNED OVER
TO FEDERAL CUSTODY FOLLOWING THE
TRIAL, BUT GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S
SANCTUARY STATE LAWS, I EXPECT
HE WILL FIND HIS WAY BACK INTO
THE GOLDEN STATE.
AND THEN THIS, IN FAIRHOPE,
ALABAMA, ON SUNDAY, A
TWICE-DEPORTED ALIEN IS ACCUSED
OF CRASHING HIS TRUCK INTO A
LOCAL WOMAN WHO WAS ON HER BIKE
AND KILLED HER.
HE WAS ALSO DRUNK.
HE TOO FLED THE SCENE OF THE
CRASH.
AUTHORITIES LATER FOUND HIM IN
POSSESSION OF A STOLEN GUN AND
BELIEVE HE HAS USED SEVEN
ALIASES IN THE PAST, THEY ARE
NOW INVESTIGATING HIS CRIMINAL
HISTORY.
A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL AND
THE SISTER OF THE VICTIM WILL
JOIN US IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
AND LAST FRIDAY IN THE SUBURBS
OF NEW ORLEANS, AT 2:00 IN THE
AFTERNOON, THIS CHARMER
SAUNTERED INTO A WALMART.
HIS NAME IS BILLY.
HE ALLEGEDLY APPROACHED A MOTHER
AND HER 2-YEAR-OLD CHILD WITH A
MACHETE.
HE TOLD THE MOTHER IF SHE DIDN'T
LISTEN TO HIS INSTRUCTIONS, SHE
AND HER CHILD WOULD DIE.
HE THEN TRIED TO KIDNAP THE
INFANT.
THE MOTHER RESISTED AND HID WITH
HER BABY BEHIND THE DELI COUNTER
HER BABY BEHIND THE DELI COUNTE
COUNTER.
HE THEN RAN OFF AND ATTEMPTED TO
ABDUCT ANOTHER CHILD FROM A
SHOPPING CART.
WALMART EMPLOYEES AND AN
OFF-DUTY OFFICER ENDED UP
TACKLING HIM.
HE IS CHARGED WITH KIDNAPPING,
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT, AND AN
IMMIGRATION DETAINER HAS BEEN
PLACED ON HIM.
LOOK, I DON'T EVEN HAVE TIME TO
REPORT ON THE OTHER CRIMES THAT
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
A TRAVELING PASTOR, NO LESS,
CHARGED JUST LAST WEEK WITH
ENTICING A 14-YEAR-OLD GIRL IN
VIRGINIA TO RECORD A SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT OF HERSELF.
INVESTIGATORS BELIEVE THIS BREAK
MAY HAVE VICTIMIZED MANY OTHERS.
OR THE GUATEMALAN, TWICE
DEPORTED, ALLEGEDLY RAPED I
TEENAGE GIRL.
HE POSTED BAIL IN FEBRUARY AND
ESCAPED BEFORE I.C.E. COULD
DETAIN HIM.
OR THE ILLEGAL CHARGE OF
SMOTHERING A SENIOR CITIZEN AND
MAY BE, ACCORDING TO
AUTHORITIES, A SERIAL KILLER.
THIS ONLY SCRATCHES THE SURFACE
OF CRIMES COMMITTED ON A DAILY
BASIS BY THOSE WHO SHOULD HAVE
NEVER BEEN IN THIS COUNTRY IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
EVERY LIFE LOST, EVERY CHILD